hey everybody I had so much fun
discussing time travel with Andre from
black nerd comedy whoa who is this
Andre I am that blend ray right I've
invited Andres alter-ego swear to pay
back to settle the ultimate geeky
question which is better Marvel or DC
Andre you want to pick one of those and
alienate half of your audience
oh no no I know how this works if I say
DC all the Marvel fan boys are gonna
hate me if I say Marvel all the DC fan
was gonna hate me so you know I'm
staying in neutral zone my favorite is
Archie I see with nothing bulky know
what why don't we chat about which
upcoming superhero movie is going to
suck the most our topic on this week's
episode of a greener and black head
first the mailman great low wrote how
about that Suicide Squad cast list I
can't wait for that film haha
it's amazing but it's a little less
amazing now that Tom Hardy Bale ones who
you replace it with Tyler Perry now I
love the fact that all of these comic
book movies are being made but I worried
that there are too many yeah the big
media narrative nowadays is halos comic
book movies are actually pretty good
make a hundred of them I mean people who
don't even read comics like myself set
for Archie love guardians of the galaxy
love the Winter Soldier but I think I'll
just take one Green Lantern woman
Blankman style bomb to spark a huge
backlash which movie has a potential
bomb so badly but it provokes that
backlash and will it be a Marvel movie
or a DC or a Marvel movie that's not in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe like say
the land that's that's really bad my
favorite fantastic
still be the roger corman women never
got released yeah and mine will be the
Incredibles oh they're gone now look
about DC's BC really laying the
groundwork for his own successful
cinematic universe no is it just copying
and pasting we can't be funny at all
just make a good movie dark and brooding
but don't think marvels are any of their
movies could be done in just by the need
of carrying this enormous series forward
is it a good thing to know that the
movie are working on is essentially a
prequel for a dozen future movies we're
having fun as exciting as comedic let's
just stop the movie for five minutes and
show that house because next Avengers
movies and worried that by 2018 every
Marvel movie will have like 30 minutes
of closing credits interrupted by a
half-dozen little teaser clips that
promote all their future movies and all
of those will feature Howard the Duck
well in that case I would like to
withdraw any reservations that would be
awesome
and plus all this tie-in that Marlin is
doing I mean before I see a movie I
gotta see five other Marvel movies for
different Netflix series agents of
shield and whatever rebooted battleworld
universe are gonna create in the comics
just know what's going on in the movie
it's like a marvel SAT but at least Bart
was tying everything together
DC sound like we're gonna have a movie
arrow and flash and a TV arrow and flash
they can't be the same what's next DC
babies don't give them any bright idea
my
so time to lay it online what are our
predictions what do we think will be the
movie that kills this whole superhero
boom I'm gonna say spider-man that
specific movie who from the amazing
spider-man fighter just just him just
spider-man in Jeb's
he's now a jinx in the movie universe I
don't even want minute vengers at this
point like I'm afraid he'll tainted like
like like just like venom like she'll
step into the movie and then just
justice bad movie dumb will flow into
the fifth Fantastic Four my spider sense
is tingling no we could talk all day
about movies it'll be like Electra Times
Catwoman times 10 and black pants and
cyborg same goes to you to your job
right be careful
so what superhero movie do you think is
going to bomb yeah let us know in the
comments
okay it was such a blast working with
you the people of Wired and I wanted to
present you with a small token of our
appreciation great you remember the hat
we gave you last time yes to return it
well this is even better can we bring
that out no we know how much you love
the turtles - give me the party wagon
jets go oh my gosh shell is that you're
welcome so big you know I flew here
right oh yeah thanks a lot for the gift
I'm not gonna have to pay $75 to check
in
be sure to subscribe to the wire channel
and while you're at it subscribe to my
channel black nerd comedy I have a bunch
of figures in the background and now a
giant Michelangelo figure will be there
too don't forget to check out our other
collaborations with Andre over here
because they will probably be our last a
lot of people tell me they look like me
without a nose oh yeah yeah if I put my
nose up like this and leave my glass I
look like Donatello from the movie hey
tip three cuz I'm smart one is how I
talk
totally see them I bet if we paint
ourselves green and going to the scent
they'll just put us in the sequel cuz
that's gonna be a great movie
I got your latte I've been mourning my
parents long before you even heard of
excuse me you dead